Kim Cattrall calls her relationship with
her Sex in the City co-stars toxic
speaking to Piers Morgan during a taping
of his show life stories Kim says she
never sees any of her classmates and
that none of them ever called the common
ground that we had was the series and
the series is over but she's
specifically calling out Sarah Jessica
Parker what is your problem I don't have
a problem you have a problem the pair
have long denied there's any animosity
between them but now Kim says SJP could
have been nicer when she recently
revealed that a third movie would not go
ahead last week tabloid reports emerged
claiming Kim's demanding behavior was
the only thing halting production on a
third film the Kim tells Peirce she
simply had no desire to reprise the role
as Samantha and she's been polite
Faliszek lining the studio's offers for
years I want them to make the movie if
that's what they want to do it's a great
part I played it past the finish line
and then some and I loved it another
actress should play it maybe they could
make it an african-american Samantha
Jones or Hispanic Samantha Jones god we
can't help but wonder how true our Kim's
words / co-star Willie Garson who play
carries friends Stanford implies that
she's lying
today he tweets dear fans because I'm
toxic I'm going to negotiate a contract
for six months not come to terms then
say I never wanted to do it anyway